.
- Ils sont près de 100 chefs
d'État et de gouvernement réunis
à Charm el-Cheikh, en Égypte.
Les premiers minide la Grde la,
de l'Espagne et de l'Italie
sont présents.
Le président de la France,
aussi, mais Justin Trudeau
ar son absence.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
premier ministre du CanadaP27 va
être menée par Steven Guilbault.
ntinuer le leadership
du Canada en matière de mettre
un prix sur la pol
à travers le monde.
- Pourtant, l'heure est grave,rl
de l'ONU.
- "Nous a plus
importante bataille de
nos vies
en train de la perdre",
dit Antoes.
"Le chaos climatique
sera bieajoute-t-il.
Une nouvelle fois, il implore
les pays participants
à collaborer pour éviter
Déjà, les délégués se sont mis
d'accord pour discuter d'une
compensation qui serait versée
par les pays riches aux pays
déjà de plein fouet l'impact
des changements climatiques.
EMMANUEL MACRON
président de la France
pas dans un an, deux ans;
au printemps proch
nous avons demandé au FMI,
à la Banque mondiale, à l'OCDE
très concrètes pour activer
ces mécanismes financiers
innovants, pour nous permettre
de développer des... l'accèsnou,
des capacités de prêts
nouvelles, pour des pays,
intermédiaires, qui sont tou
par ces chocs.
- "On ne veut pas de nouvelles
promesses d'aide financière,
rétorque ce militant africain;
que les pays riches soient
redevables de tout ce qu'ils
ont déjà promis."
ont dix jours pour prouver
qu'ils sont prêts à passer
de la parole aux actes.
Ici Lise Villeneu